I got blown open my emergence into
Enlightenment was not at all what I was
expecting if Source gave you all of
sources information in your physical
body you can't store that much
information in Your Capacity I was given
as much as would not kill me and nothing
less so because of that I hear like
nothing less I about short-circuited I
short-circuited I literally short
circuit my meridians after that I was
like in this weird wonky land which I
understand now is actually initiations
um after Enlightenment Enlightenment is
to understand that you
are the other person and the other
person is you your different expressions
of source so you are the all but you are
also an ambassador of the Earl you know
we were talking about names earlier I'm
Sarah yeah no after Enlightenment I had
to go
I'm Sarah how funny